c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
ah oui j'ai une petite fille alors voilà
attention le qui aura la plus longue
stéphane alesi choisissez le perdant
devra se mettre là et le gagnant aura
une petite tige et bien sûr voilà voilà
mais c'est très sympa vous inquiétez
projet là qui je l'aï cela parce que
c'est moi qui ai gagné alors allez-y
stéphane c'est un jeu digne de la taupe
alors j'aimerais aller salon sont galère
avec cette tige ans
et bien sûr
moi non
alors
[Musique]
ma gueule égard alors stéphane allez je
vais me battre
donc là vous avez alors attend de moi
d'être mal truc j'attendais je vous
donne mon micro alors l'oreillette
volant on sauve tout alors un dernier
mot avant avant l'exécution chose à dire
que je donne tout ou à gilles verdez
voilà gilles je te donne tout bouge il
je t'aime pas tout fatou le dit jamais à
jules ce qui s'est passé entre nous pas
tous merci c'est dans ses derniers mots
ok on y va ça en pet et oui j'ai un deal
à vous faire si vous si vous prenez ma
place demain je dirais toutes les
missions toutes les cinq minutes qui a
qui est là tôt sur m6 ajoute je prends
bon bah voilà allez c'est bon bah voilà
allez merci et le voilà nommé thomas
pourrait vérifier toutes les cinq
minutes
oui retirer tout ce que vous voulez
retirer voulu retient votre slip allez
thomas toutes les cinq minutes je le
dirai mans stéphane toute la serbie de
toutes les servitudes
attention attention premier ou est
promis sur sûr et on y va
eh ben voilà
quant à damas
s'amuse à jeter sa ministre le dispense
t par an espère que j'attaque paddock
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]